der titel dieses videos ist insofern
irreführend weil ich derzeit gar nicht
genau weiß wie groß mein baby ist wenn
ihr euch jetzt fragt moment mal habe ich
irgendwas verpasst
nein das hier ist meine art euch zu
sagen dass ich schwanger bin
hallo elf zentimeter dass so ein
durchschnittswert ich werde das beim
nächsten ultraschall wirklich wissen wie
groß es ist könnten auch schon 14 cm
sein was mich gar nicht wundern würde
können wir doch messen 29 zentimeter ich
wollte ein video darüber machen nicht
nur weil ich es nicht mehr lange
verstecken kann sondern auch um euch zu
erzählen wie die letzten monate waren
und was jetzt noch kommt und was das
ganze für den kanal also für meile
bedeutet morgen also wenn dieses video
raus kommt fängt mein fünfter monat an
das heißt ich habe schon einiges hinter
mir
die ersten drei monate der
schwangerschaft sind sehr aufregend aber
auch ein bisschen doof vielen frauen
geht es in diesem ersten trimester
ziemlich schlecht also erst mal
körperlich der körper macht extreme
veränderungen durch also nicht nur dass
da jetzt ein mensch ein [ __ ] mensch in
meinem bauch ist dass ich gerade zwei
menschen bin sondern es verändert sich
alles also von deiner haut über
irgendwie pigmentierung ich habe gerade
derzeit zehn prozent mehr blut in meinem
körper sind jetzt bei mir
schätzungsweise 300 noch was milliliter
also moment nur mal zur visualisierung
so viel mehr blut habe ich gerade in
meinem körper und bis zum ende der
schwangerschaft wird man blutvolumen um
50 prozent steigen also es sind es
passieren so viele abgefahrene dinge mit
meinem körper da natürlich noch die
ganzen schwangerschaftshormon mit denen
man sich bisher im leben doch
herumschlagen musste also noch nie in
diesem ausmaß nun mal ist beispiel das
sogenannte hcg hormon also dass das
hormon das auch auf den
schwangerschaftstest delektiert wird
steigt in der schwangerschaft um 1 40
bis 50 tausendfaches an ist natürlich
auch rein wissenschaftlich medizinisch
sehr spannend was gerade alles passiert
ich habe mir hier zum einstieg sondern
taschen lehrbuch embryologie gekauft
dass manche medizinstudenten glaube ich
auch im studium mal haben und ich kann
es nicht empfehlen
ich zeige euch mal dass ein bisschen
weiter weg war ich wäre euch nicht
zerstören aber es sind halt unglaublich
viele unschöne bilder drin von fällen
was auch alles schief gehen kann
und solche bilder möchte man dass
werdende mutter einfach nicht sehen also
es ist es ist ein bisschen brutal aber
die informationen die da drin steht
die sind wenigstens verifiziert dafür
bin ich dann doch ganz dankbar wenn ihr
wisst ihr wie es ist im internet gibt es
eine fülle von informationen und man
weiß hat einfach nie ob sie stehen oder
nicht jedenfalls all diese veränderungen
im körper kommen nicht ohne
nebenwirkungen also man kennt ja die
berühmte morgenübelkeit die bei den
meisten dabei nicht nur morgens ist
sondern immer aber die liste der
beschwerden ist vielfältig also ich
hatte oft ziemlich schwere
bauchschmerzen nach dem essen hat
irgendwie verdauungsprobleme
ich war extrem extrem müde wer mir näher
erfolg hat vielleicht schon mitbekommen
dass ich eigentlich ein ziemlich die sie
leben habe also ich arbeite sehr viel
die arbeit macht halt sehr viel spaß
ich habe häufig 16 stunden tage ich
schlafe ziemlich wenig und das hat sich
dann alles sehr schlagartig geändert
also ich musste am anfang der
schwangerschaft manchmal nach dem
frühstück direkt wieder schlafen gehen
und ein ich bin nicht ganz dankbar dass
das kleine nicht doch sehr erfolgreich
dazu gezwungen hat mehr zu schlafen weil
schlaf sehr gesund ist wie wir wissen
spätestens seit unserem video zu
schlafentzug und ausgerechnet in diesen
ersten drei monaten wo so viel los ist
kannst du niemandem davon erzählen also
zumindest wird das empfohlen dass man es
die ersten drei monate das erste
trimester es mario held weil das risiko
für eine fehlgeburt da noch recht hoch
ist und klar wenn dann doch irgendwas
schiefgeht dann möchtest du halt nicht
dass die ganze welt schon davon weißen
hatten also dieses riesige geheimnis
dass manche nur schwer geheimhalten
können zum beispiel wenn sie jeden tag
putzen müssen wir hatten halt das glück
habt ihr mitbekommen dass wir den
letzten monat meines ersten trainer ist
das weg waren wir waren vier wochen in
den usa und so musste ich mir wenigstens
nicht jeden tag irgendeine ausrede
einfallen lassen warum ich
nicht arbeiten kann weil ich den ganzen
tag schlafen muss wie geht's jetzt viel
besser gott sei dank wie den meisten
frauen geht es mir da dass das zweite
trimester deutlich entspannter ist als
das erste aber ich habe nicht die selbe
power wie vor der schwangerschaft das
merke ich schon deutlich und das fällt
mir nicht schwer zu akzeptieren denn das
ist jetzt erstmal das wichtigste hier
drin
eine konsequenz daraus habt ihr
vielleicht schon festgestellt nämlich
seinerzeit kommen die videos auf diesem
kanal nicht immer jeden donnerstag ganz
strikt sondern vielleicht auch erst
freitags oder sonntags das wird auch
erstmal so weiter gehen weil ich
versuche das hat so möglichst entspannt
zu halten also vor der schwangerschaft
habe ich sehr gerne mal die nachtschicht
eingelegt damit das video noch
rechtzeitig kommt die arbeit macht halt
sehr viel spaß aber das mache ich jetzt
natürlich nicht mehr also ich passe auch
nicht auf und ich weiß dass sie der
super support website also danke auch
dafür und jetzt ist halt auch bescheid
sowie geht es hier weiter
mai lab wird kein baby kanal keine sorge
hier wird so weitergehen wie bisher mit
guten wissenschaftlichen themen wir
haben einiges auf der liste und wie
gesagt ihr könnt auch immer gerne in die
kommentare schreiben was euch so
einfällt teilen so viel zu meinem
updates damit ist es jetzt ganz
offiziell und ich muss jetzt vor
wirklich niemandem mehr verstecken
wir sehen uns in ungefähr einer woche
und bis dahin bleibt sicher